if you have a smashed up iPhone Pro like
I do then you'll see that there's this
little useless looking thing right here
if I put the phone onto portrait mode or
onto cinematic mode then you'll see what
it does look at this there's actually a
tiny flashing laser coming from it
what's it doing well you want to get
photos with that nice background blur
like this but actually the phone fakes
it and the way it does it is by figuring
out which objects are actually further
away from the camera and how it does it
is very clever it measures how long it
takes for that little light coming from
the back of this phone to hit an object
and come back and if that time is very
short then that means that it needs to
be a close by object and if it's long it
means it's a further away object so I
thought why don't I use this technology
to test whether light really does slow
down in water